as the election campaign crackles into
life more than 50 MPs have decided to
step away from the fray over lunch in a
quiet corner of Westminster we tried to
find out why say many well-known faces
will be missing from the green benches
after the 12th of December there's been
quite a lot of them MPs who've been
standing down recently and barad for
example announced recently I'm Heidi
Allen some of these and peace have
spoken about the difficulties of the job
know the abuse of stressors that
obviously the brexit debate has been
quite toxic at times have you seen
anything like this in your time at
parliament
well the toxicity I mean I believe you
know I do you know I'm sure you've had a
lot of it it can be very nasty but it
involves actually listening to incoming
social media which you don't have to do
but that's where a lot of the toxicity
is I have to say I don't feel in some
ways it's as bad as it's been in the
past I mean I was politically active in
the days of Enoch Powell's rivers of
blood and I had a mixed marriage so you
know for me that was the low point in
British political history as homes of
toxicity and violence and you know we
had the Thatcher years and the miners
strike and the poll tax rats and
actually people are not being violent
you know despite all these threats that
Breck's it's going to lead to rioting
and cheering most people are actually
quite rational and dispassionate about
it how do you agree with that then or do
you think that it has been a bit more
toxic than I think I am so used to the
abuse that is going to take me a little
while once I'm out of the other side so
it has just become a fact of life it's
only on social media of the rights so I
assume that when the word MP is removed
from high social media then it will
reduce but I'm used to it and I don't
think that's healthy actually like that
I used to it I think the difference is
we're more accessible than we were and
I'm not been site that I've had to do
with social media I cannot see the point
I couldn't send a tweet saved my life
you know but there's a bogus Twitter
site
many all that and the female MPs in
particular the women seemed to get
abused horrendously by these anonymous
people whose sad people sitting in their
bed seats sending abuse out I quite
understand what sort of abuse some
people have been getting it's all very
well for me it is difficult to be
totally laid-back about the face to face
versus the anonymous I mean during the
coalition particularly at the beginning
you know I had people spitting in the
streets and in a real unpleasantness
which I don't go I mean my friend even
the brexit ears tend to be quite polite
beats me I didn't know but I don't have
that kind of physical aggression where
but in the indirect anonymous world of
social media you do get it how are you
feeling about the thought of standing
down after so long in Parliament well is
it's I slightly sad but I really and
disability of so long it just didn't I
was I was invited to retire I said I
wasn't gonna stand again after the 2015
election and then we had this funny
unexpected election so I changed my mind
and did one more but I've known I was
gonna retire for ages well I always
thought when I stood for Parliament that
probably around a decade for me was what
I had in mind now if I had wanted to
stay for longer though after the last
I'm not sure I would have done anyway
and do you think the pressures have been
more recently than the last four years
has been has been tough because of
course it's not just the Braxley debate
but that was preceded by a civil war in
the labour party a bittersweet you know
it's a sweet on the days when you think
of all the things I'm going to do next
and it's bitter when you realise you no
longer part of the action but I think in
my case I had an unplanned retirement in
2015 but way back so I've now got a
planned retirement and it's based on
leaving the party in reasonably good
shape and having other things I want to
do
I mean I you know halfway through a book
had the newspaper column my dancing
teacher is preparing me for program
competition to sir
I left his number five years I've been I
ate sis and I probably wouldn't be
capable of doing any of those things so
I'm getting off now so you gonna be
doing dancing competitions yes yes I've
been lined up for Blackpool next year
okay what do you plan on doing and well
my children ask that question rather
nervously every now and again shall no
doubt continue be obsessed with politics
but following my usual you know
earnestness from a slight distance
slightly amused to detached observation
of the next extraordinary turn of events
might be you've got the referendum yes I
do my friend and I've sort of got the
thought of putting the country through
that again I just couldn't I have argued
against doing that the last one did
disastrous have yeah our political
institutions do you think we might get
to some compromise soft brexit after
this election I can't see you but that
would be an elegant way out they might
have to because the likely outcome is a
hung parliament I think yeah I don't
know no one can predict a different way
and then the the the one way of
resolving it is to have a soft rang
saved which we nearly got with Theresa
Mays deal actually came closer as well
would you argue well he said he's older
yeah he what he got through was a funny
version of Theresa's deal but then he
wanted to have an election so he used
the excuse that he didn't want
Parliament to debate or discuss it and
suddenly because this is called the
selection well if it emerges if people
feel this Gloria does the one thing that
could emerge is going back to something
like Teresa's deal and then leaving the
EU staying in the single market staying
in the customs union now I think the
Scot knacks would want a referendum I'm
quite interested to see
know some of your predictions of
Elections I know it's gonna be really
hard that is my that is wonderful
guarantee I can make about election hi
you you have quite an interesting
perspective on this though don't you
because you have one of these labor
leave voting seats that the
Conservatives are really targeting I
mean do you think there is enough of
those seats that they could potentially
win to get a majority I'm so nervous
about making predictions all I can say
is that I knock on doors a lot because
I've got a marginal seat I mean it's
ridiculous in some ways that's a
Heartland labour for a mining community
is now the battleground but that's where
we are but when I am knocking on doors
I'm not finding labour voters who voted
labour in 2017 moving away from us so
and I am here so we'll be fighting our
butts off and I am looking forward to
being a volunteer for a fantastic new
candidate but you know it's it's not
easy to see how you think all the ones
who might have moved did move in 2017
that's what to another not every MP was
a surprisingly close run for you so they
don't seem to be moving again and the
Lib Dems are gonna be really interesting
aren't they as well I mean I could see
quite a lot of headway the question is
how much headway I mean the Tories are
going to lose quite a lot of seats in
Scotland up to 20 they may gain
something in I don't know about glorious
eight but that type of seat then the
balancing factor was how many remain
seats in mainly in the South of England
I'm not supposedly we win and the upside
is very big and the downside is not many
and and that's the big Impala rule well
if the Conservatives don't win Ashfield
then the whole Dominic Cummings the
theory of people versus Parliament and
winning white working-class voters
it's nonsense because Ashfield Ida
thought is obvious first one in our part
of the world and if they can't win
Ashfield they won't be very well north
of the trend as mr. Cummings apparently
finally imagines they're going to
[Laughter]